good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier President Trump is responding
to calls for greater regulations on
rapid-fire weaponry like that used in
last week's Florida school shooting and
in Las Vegas last year he's calling on
the Justice Department to come up with
new rules on so-called bump stocks that
increased the speed at which bullets can
be fired bump stocks were used in the
Las Vegas shooting not Florida but the
move could either be a signal by this
president of more things to come or a
move to just do something ahead of
meetings this week about the next steps
after a long string of mass shootings
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts trusts us all tonight from the
North Lawn with an announcement no one
really saw coming John no because it's
been more than 140 days that we've heard
nothing from the president his big event
today which we saw over your shoulder
breath was to honor first responders who
risked their lives to save others
the Florida shooting and the issue of
how to keep guns out of the hands of
killers front and center in the wake of
the Douglass High School massacre
President Trump today reached back to
the last mass shooting Las Vegas
announcing that he will seek a ban on
so-called bump stock that allowed the
shooter there to fire off so many rounds
so quickly just a few moments ago I
signed a memorandum directing the
Attorney General to propose regulations
to ban all devices that turn legal
weapons into machine guns
I expect that these critical regulations
will be finalized Jeff very soon as he
recognized today the valor of safety
officers who responded to yet another
mass shooting San Bernardino in 2015 the
president praised the heroism of those
who sacrificed their lives last week in
the aftermath of this evil massacre our
spirits have been lifted by the accounts
of bravery at the Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School who have shown us
that the forces of love and courage are
always stronger than the forces of evil
and hate Douglass High School is the
first mass shooting at his school since
President Trump took
today he pledged to take steps he said
would actually make a difference the key
in all of these efforts as I said in my
remarks the day after the shooting is
that we cannot merely take actions that
make us feel like we are making a
difference
we must actually make a difference the
president will hold listening sessions
this week on school shootings tomorrow
he will meet students and teachers from
Douglass High School Sandy Hook
Elementary and other schools Thursday
he'll meet with state and local
officials to hear what they have to say
president Trump has voiced support for a
Senate bill that seeks to make the
background check system more efficient
but when pressed the press secretary
indicated more needs to be done the
president is very focused on Mental
Illness working with the Health and
Human Services Department to determine
the best path forward on that and what
is available and allowed under the law
unfortunately we can't just flip a
switch but there is a process there we
are a law-and-order country and the
president is trying to do everything
that he can under his capacity to
address these concerns and certainly
when it comes to mental illness the
White House today also defended a tweet
president Trump was widely criticized
for on the weekend he said that the FBI
missed all of the many signals sent out
by the Florida school shooter because
they are spending too much time trying
to prove Russia collusion with the Trump
campaign the point that we would like
our FBI agencies to to not be focused on
something that is clearly a hoax in
terms of investigating the Trump
campaign and its involvement four days
after robert muller announced
indictments against 13 russians for
interfering in u.s. elections President
Trump today faulted the Obama White
House we're not taking Russian meddling
more seriously and while the president
made no effort to call out the Russians
after Muller's announcement the White
House today insisted President Trump has
been far harder on Russia than the Obama
administration ever was he helped push
through 700 billion dollars to rebuild
our military he's helped export energy
to Eastern Europe he's closed three
diplomatic
Bertie's that were Russia's here in the
United States he's helped arm the
Ukrainians through a number of places
that Obama was too weak and refused to
take and put pressure on Russia where
this president has president Trump also
took a swing at the Obama White House
and his memorandum to the Attorney
General looking to ban bump stocks
pointing out that the Obama
administration repeatedly concluded that
bump stocks were legal to purchase and
possess Brett John Roberts live in the
North Lawn John thanks